good morning John today here in the US
it is Black Friday the day that we turn
off our lights between 6:00 and 7:00
p.m. to honor all of the sailors lost at
se before the introduction of the US
Lighthouse service in the 1700s is a
fact that I wish was true but it's not
and that would be lovely though
something like that but no instead it's
like one day we're like I'm so grateful
for what I have and then the next day
it's like I got to get more stuff now
look of course holiday shopping is not
about getting more for yourself it's
about getting some stuff for people you
love so I'm not not saying it's bad but
it is weird and also it's not weird
because it turns out that Thanksgiving
is on the day that it is for shopping
reason but if you think you know this
story it's weirder than that early in
the history of the us we had a holiday
that we no longer have it was called
evacuation day and it happened on the
last Thursday of November it was the day
that the British left this country for
good until of course they came back
which they do now largely to shop
weirdly enough eventually Thanksgiving
kind of took over for evacuation day
completely and in Most states it was the
last day of November which Lincoln
decided would be the entire country and
after the Civil War was over and
reconstruction happened everyone indeed
celebrated Thanksgiving on the last day
of November now if you are clever and
from America you will note that's not
when we are celebrating Thanksgiving
this year this year it's the second to
last Thursday in November but some years
it is the last Thursday in November and
how the heck did that happened oh boy
well in 1939 Franklin Dela Roosevelt
decided all on his own that thanks
should be the second to last Thursday in
November to give people more time to
shop before Christmas and he decided to
let America know about this on October
31st he was like yo this is great it's
going to be November tomorrow
Thanksgiving is going to be on a
different day than you thought happy
Halloween trick or treat people hated
this now a lot of people who really
loved FDR were like yeah we'll give it
to you but most people hated this like
70% of the country was like why would
you do that especially especially on
such short notice especially opposed to
it were all the people who hated FDR of
which there were many they indeed
mockingly called it franksgiving after
Franklin Delano Roosevelt his main
Republican Challenger the guy who ran
against him said that he had sprung this
on an unprepared country with quote the
omnipotence of a Hitler so those people
very much wanted to keep Thanksgiving
where it was the last Thursday in
November that also didn't happen because
of this entirely unhinged franksgiving
situation a bunch of different states
started celebrating Thanksgiving at
different times and Congress actually
had to step in and say okay we're going
to make a compromise and that's going to
be the most confusing of all possible
options Thanksgiving will not be the
last Thursday of the month or the second
to last Thursday of the month it'll be
the fourth Thursday of the month I'm 43
years old I am still confused about this
I'm like how could it be the 23rd this
year when it was the 28th last that
doesn't make any sense and so
Thanksgiving can happen anywhere between
the 22nd and the 28th of November which
I find annoying this new rule gave us a
few more days of the Christmas season
but it does turn out that FDR was at
least like a little bit right because on
years where there are more days between
Thanksgiving and Christmas employment
numbers in the US at least significantly
increased so yeah for a little while
there was a separate Thanksgiving for
republicans and Democrats adorable very
American of you America and that is why
Black Friday is today and not a week
from now which it would have been if FDR
hadn't got his bright idea but it is
Black Friday and I should tell you that
at good do store we already donate 100%
of our profit to charity so look you
don't need to use a discount code there
you can find my cancer socks which I'm
also wearing right now and all the money
from those goes to make access to cancer
treatment more Equitable there are still
two Garfield a day going out in those if
you don't know what that means that's
fine good dot store also offers the
amazing awesome coffee club and Sun
Basin soap Sun Basin soap has several
holiday boxes priced from $25 to $99 you
can do a lot of holiday shopping at good
dot store and if you go over $75
shipping will be free another nice gift
or just nice thing to have for yourself
is a calendar and complexly has done
four of them we have our James web Space
Telescope our micr photography from
microcosmos the delightful illustrations
of bizarre beasts and the eon's calendar
of some of your early ancestors those do
have a 10% discount right now if you use
the code save the date cuz that's cute
right and final thing I finally did the
2022 nerd Feria census been a little
busy this year so I didn't get around to
it until now but it was really fun and
lovely and it is uploaded on Hank's
Channel John I'll see you on Tuesday